how many jobs have you had how many do
you expect to have over the course of
your career well the scary thing is that
number has historically been around 12.
but in the future I predict it'll be
closer to 20 or 30 or more
and a lot of those jobs don't even exist
yet
this future of work sounds overwhelming
especially when you take into account
our old-fashioned system of resumes job
postings and applicant tracking systems
it's hard enough to navigate just a
single career transition but you're far
more prepared than you think to navigate
your next job change and all the ones
that come after
I'm Dr Michelle Weiss and I advise
companies and educational institutions
on how to prepare workers for successful
and longer careers right now I want to
talk about how you can navigate that
longer career starting with your next
job change number one
highlight your human skills when we talk
about skills we tend to focus on hard
skills like coding editing data
visualization or budgeting but human
skills need to share the spotlight too
these are skills like adaptability
collaboration exercising judgment or
mediating tense situations they may not
always show up in obvious ways on your
resume but they have enormous value to
surface your human skills make a
timeline of all of your experiences both
personal and professional do you see
patterns have certain skills grown over
time maybe your stint is a barista made
you a great team player or good at
communicating in chaos
or maybe your experience is a caregiver
for a child or someone with special
needs gave you strengths like patience
or empathy which informs how you design
human-centered digital products or guide
teams through a reorganization human
skills are deeply transferable you might
surprise yourself by how prepared you
already are for your next role second
become a skills translator
you need to translate your skills into
the language of your prospective
employer research the industry you want
to move into because the same skill can
have vastly different meanings depending
on the context for instance when a
marketing position is asking for a
candidate who's strong in communication
they're usually looking for you to
display storytelling or branding skills
but when a behavioral health position
mentions communication it's likely the
employer is looking for your experience
with counseling or crisis management
become their translator third
find data in discomfort at work when do
you feel uncomfortable
maybe you feel out of depth when people
bring up a new technology or platform or
maybe someone at your current
organization got the raise or promotion
that you wanted pay attention to those
signals that kind of discomfort is good
it's data telling you where you need to
level up sign up for a course to get up
to speed on that new platform or
application transform that discomfort
around your skills gaps into action
finally get picky you shouldn't be the
only one committed to your skill
development your employer should be too
the next time you change jobs try to
choose a company or organization that is
building Talent from within look at
LinkedIn and see if people have risen
within the company ask during the
interview whether there are clear road
maps for internal advancement the
reality is most companies have so much
work to do when it comes to recognizing
human skills spotting talent in
unexpected places and cultivating the
careers of their own employees you want
an employer that takes the law Long View
on your career and can help you fill
your skills gaps on the job even if the
job market can feel broken at times
remember you can take control you can
steer the process you can Surface your
hidden skills translate your strengths
and level up your gaps you can show
employers new ways to think about why
they should hire you and when you do all
of those Lane changes ahead will feel a
whole lot less intimidating and maybe
even a little exciting